c'est au nom de cette semaine encore
parfois de petites tortues viennent
compléter le patron de l'aiea avaient
fait 80 début 90
et pour lancer samedi à la gare
c'était vraiment ridicule non seulement
les années 80 et 90 pour ceux qui ont
pas connu cette époque les jeux vidéo
et les décès liés au sida
par exemple les gens sont super connue
la tentation serait resté plus de trois
mois numéro 1 du top 50 bordeaux qu'il
y avait des chansons un peu moins
profondes briand avait aussi qui
stipulerait dans l'église d'aujourd'hui
on peut trouver ça carrément mauvais
voilà la légende de zebda
les années 80 90 c'est aussi l'époque
des plus petites faisait baver plus d'un
pas
l'une des plus mémorables j
paris 12 juil
c'est d'ailleurs le seul peut-être de
stadiers je suis sûr que tout le monde
souhaite que le monde se préparait dans
les couloirs que j'étais petit m
laurent
1 mais les années 80 et 90 mais
c'était aussi l'époque de plus que
l'émission
le désistement de comparable en route
pour l'aventuré c'était une mission
pour la sauvegarde de monter sur le dos
de sa mère pour des courses et des
fidèles qui étaient compliquées à
cause de son mode de société
elle salue je crois que tout le monde a
répondu coup pour être à leur place
mais c'était pas la seule émission
comme ça il est possible chevalier du
labyrinthe où l'on voit sa belle
plastique empêché de voir et de ne pas
se faire décorer mais c'est au
contraire
la vente de produits divers
dvd est née une idée de la difficulté
pas plus tard
je vais aussi cyberflânage émissions
de jeux vidéo de canal+ avec des gros
nichons depuis lors la présentatrice de
wikileaks elle est gogo des virunga
claquer quelques lacunes de tes parents
de la facture de téléphone un désir
de participer à l'émission
je travaille
il ya des téléviseurs port-de-bouc
célébrer l'été moment et sans pitié
à tous les gamers fr de faire un film
en seconde période c'était pendant
qu'il était rempli des missions qui
était super sympa
et aussi de quelques émissions des
testaments connaît suffit que tu avais
l'impression et regardons plutôt
intelligent s'était inspiré dans un
trou noir
alors autant dans cette catégorie
franchement j'pourrai rangez pas mal de
séries de l'époque le miracle de
l'amour les vacances de l'amour premier
baiser
le collège de coeur brisé de cellules
trouvées et le miel et les abeilles
hélène et les garçons
je vais pas en parler parce que
je m'excuse je n'ai pas eu le courage de
me taper 600 épisodes du miel et des
abeilles pour préparer cette émission
faut pas déconner quand même
bon à savoir pour le moment si ces
risques souvent le moment que les filles
attendent à la fin de l'année
kontic rapport aux autres comme ça
putain ça barde pour moi aussi si en
plus ils en auront vraiment
les berruyères s'étaient retrouvés
l'extrait le plus viril de peine et les
garçons
les garde-côtes
les racailles des années 90
car le sport de vienne comme ça ça
fait pas peur
au cours du repas à thème il va lancer
un petit caillou qui rapportera pas
parfaite ça va me porter
mais c'est évident
il suffit d'écouter la culture
qu'est-ce qui explique cette situation
voir le programme détaillé des mots
qui doit être revoté là il ya 25 ans
je rechercherai grosses feuilles ce soit
avec le sac banane de saint-gaudens
c'est notre souhait
non
lors de l'annoncé à l'appel pourquoi
maintenant la fête je vais parler d'une
autre émission qui m'a un peu près
autant marqué que télécharger dans un
autre style
pas de thiers
pour le croissant
alors je précise que j'adore dorothée
et sa bande je pense que dorothée pour
moi et pour beaucoup de gens et pour
cette épreuve pour le deuxième
mais seulement l'émission pas de pitié
pour les croissants mais
c'est aussi fait pour le cerveau que le
bourg de la même cour d'ailleurs je
crois que même les animateurs savait
pas ce qu'il faisait ce qui est
déclinable bronze pour les concours
pour les jeunes qui connaissent pas pas
de pitié pour les croissants c'était
ça
compaoré
utilisez votre langue
rasmussen
on parle de comiris fernandez
chanson du pompier enfin euros par mois
pour une fois par an
en fait cette émission symbole majeur
au sein du club dorothée c'est des
petits sketchs réalisé par l'équipe
est entrecoupée de plusieurs morceaux
de chansons
et pour cause je me souviens clairement
que même quand j'avais 6 ans je trouve
ça déjà complètement con dorothée
comme ça
j'ai choisi ap
poite heureusement que je me sens le
rôle croissant de la bourse
je sais pas pour vous mais moi j'étais
presque gêné de regarder ça
je veux dire c'est un an je crois que
c'était la seule émission rapporter
les publicités le potentiel de tout
détruire les neurones
le plus dramatique pour moi je crois que
c'est le maroc qui change
quand on est confronté à ce genre de
produit toujours l'impression que mon
service et c'était impossible
l'om
je peu
en option pour moi je suis trop vieux
pour ces conneries j'attends toujours
ce
on commence à douter de vos objets dont
le sol regorge de scènes
il faut se souvenir que l'émission je
n'avance pas la photo pendant les
vacances a duré presque toute la
journée sur quasiment toute la chaîne
le patron du club au billet vert un bus
trois roulés vie comme sur la
croissance
les antennes de gamme et chalumeau et
inefficace qui était arrivé un peu
plus tard je crois que c'est toujours
l'équipe qui se rendait caduque il faut
que tu peux faire ce que je veux mais tu
pouvais faire c'était pour la paix
entre les schémas techniques d animer
toute la journée il avait été
excellent dessin animé sur le jeune
c'est pas par exemple j'avais vu 10 31
moi j'ai adoré cette série le
générique l'histoire le dessin animé
qui était magnifique
yann pochet pas que je sais pas si je
suis le seul mais des fois je la trouve
même temps pressenti par moments
il entre par exemple le passage dans
l'espace des peupliers par une musique
assez flippant
les chercheurs ont utilisé d
l'ordinateur d'un salarié
j'aime bien marc charrier
mais également beaucoup moins drôle
mais m
il a répondu
new delhi bon
impossible pour le départ du pouvoir
l'animatrice hélène mandroux
mais en plus de ce monde
et sinon le résultat des primaires ont
fait surface un peu cela petite soeur
dépressive de moscou m
djakarta reuters
le gouvernement de laurent gbagbo
karim benzema ne mène à rien
maintenant
m georges catala par la marée pas
d'accord
dès samedi avait lieu la nuit aussi
évidemment ça sentait la série que je
regarde en cachette en tête comme
l'arrêt des appels d'offres sur les
sept un truc un peu coquin veut convoyer
la drogue pour l'entendre et du coup je
voulais pas faire choper à regarder
sans
perso si c'était pour tous les gamins
étaient forcément amoureux de
personnages de dessins animés moral aux
français dans la foulée
moi ce qui me choque
les artisans prochain ferrat
enfin je crois
celle-ci demeure sur la croix de l'orme
des demandeurs dans mon précédent
sujet pourquoi j'avais dit que je n'ai
pas beaucoup de beurre
le prix de sa vie mais il ya des dessins
animés comme ça où les routes et
naftal mokhtari pas apprécié la série
moi je n'avais plusieurs passagers de
presse sparadrap plutôt tendre ailleurs
jusqu'ici
si jamais compris pourquoi pas dès que
des merdes le matin à 7 heures le but
et qui mettait tous les bourgs de sa
douleur de perdre son père avait
toujours quelques heures devant l'écran
mais pour de mauvaises raisons et
d'autres dont le générique
autant pour lui que je pouvais pas à le
supporter afro k
ok alors je cours pas après la logique
dans les cartons des commandes de sa
notoriété pour moi ça m'énerve je
veux dire
prenez le déguisement de deux meilleurs
chronos en soit pas avoir la moindre
chance de marcher
enfin il a quand même eu plus de trois
mètres qui traîne derrière lui un
coupon de 1 mètre cube pour les
explications de bernard fournis par les
personnages là franchement c'est
fantastique
ça fait trois morts en espagne en
france à paris
à ce n'est pas exactement un ballon
c'est une sorte d'ersatz la mort de son
meilleur ami il est tout à fait
inoffensif vous vous par les bras m'en
tombent du ciel c'est un bon présage
j'apporte à voir si cet accord alors on
peut parler de la nouvelle c3 ap ap
l'histoire
menton et toulon
1 portugais et un suisse
alors comme il se
cette structure aura pas de problème
au mois sur le parquet
marty singer les patentes de deux heures
et vers pékin de dinosaures envie
et tout le monde s'en foutait dans cette
affaire pour moi c'était vraiment
on persévère
le but est d'éviter ainsi que pour les
paroles
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
l
non
pourquoi
on se bat encore pour deux personnes en
france et on avait plein de titres de
sibérie qui correspondent pas du tout
aux détenus
très sérieusement je me demande si
demain qui écrivaient les génériques
avaient regardé au moins un épisode à
vendre
enfin par exemple pour oliver stone
pourquoi pour vous pour vous de voter
pour eux de savoir en allemagne voit
quasiment plus
d'ailleurs dans le top c'est bien sympa
de voir des pays européens et surtout
la française et du japon
on peut dire qu'ils nous ont bien cerné
en quelque sorte à l'arrivée au stade
de france fonctionneront
le grand classique ou de notre équipe
nationale aln tout comme la corruption
des arbitres six mois
vous allez jouer
sainte-livrade
l'arbitré accorde pas non plus la
croissance est forte
du côté des français
ah oui ça peut pas continuer comme ça
la parole les français ont dû
l'acheter
et surtout nous en france on a des
impacts extraordinaire qu'on est le seul
à s'en faire
marguerite portable
c'était la panique
on peut alors faire face à toutes et à
tous la taille de la tour effeil pour
mieux comprendre
tous les ascenseurs qui compte de chaque
côté
le grimpeur
hélas on finit par se rejoindre
ça s'appelle faire des passes
décisives
ensuite tu prends jamais servi
pourquoi fleury je n'ai jamais vu
remettre aussi transparent il apparaît
qu'une fois tous les dix épisodes pour
faire fondre de beau gosse après
disparaît
attention un appareil de neuf heures
si la statistique puma 16 la question
qu'il quitte
66'
c'est depuis la parution dans un camion
les chevaliers du zodiaque possible du
travail en amont avec le résultat que
personne n'avait qu'à plus de monde
c'est évident
les chevaliers du zodiaque
vous avez fait le dos rond
elle est solide d'accès au total
ou alors d'un judoka
l parcours
au forum
en fait du karaté
de plus le vent en poupe
les membres du réseau
alors ok j'ai d'abord essayé de me
violer pas très connue je voulais qu'on
comprend qu'on se serre les coudes et
celui plus récent deuxième de
milan-sanremo
en fait j'aime beaucoup le chemin des
filets mais je parle de voir les choses
du même genre - 10 par exemple
dans ce parcours exceptionnel j'ai
jamais réussi à aller très loin par
exemple jeudi au budget jamais réussi
à
la longueur d'avancé
moi ce que je l'apprécié pas trop dans
ce genre de truc c'est que c'est un
moyen de schéma typique d'épisodes qui
va se reproduire presque tout le temps
c'est pareil pour pokémon en inde par
exemple de ce type de pokémon de se
rassembler à sable une fois encore on
retrouve sache si c'est mikari petite
ville de trou du cul de poule
ap ap ap ap
voire même un peu patraque ababacar
fall débat par saint-lazare à paris de
temps
un apple
analyse
l'assureur legal apparaît comme un
revers à deux mains sur les tables
renseignements tél
même si la star wars 2
l'impact du mmm a pas de date
pourcentage de victoires
le score du jour
barack obama restait à abattre mais il
s'attarde à un vin s'engagent parfois
par phrase dans l'artois
plus tôt au tard dans la
soc pappalardo alors à ordan-larroque
dépourvu de joe dassin pas la même
chose on trouve un schéma identique
entre madrid et autres
bolloré ou lyon pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ce menu métier centré
autour du personnage de luc bondy qui
possède un colis qui lui fait changer
sa personnalité à chaque fois qu'il
doit livrer un duel de bon sens est-ce
que je suis schizophrène non pas que le
parena pharaons égyptiens la gale
et l'histoire commence donc au début
parce que quand il parle de la place de
l'egypte le cartographe de duels de
monstres que possède le grand-père
2010 je vais peut-être choquer les fans
de cette série mais le noyau dur je
trouve que ça ressemble presque à une
parodie de shauna l'ont fait
mon père pour les pilotes de l'avion
dans ma tête et de dire stop pourquoi
est-ce que le fait qu'un prétexte et
puis plus tard je vois pas comme un
décalque j'ai pas de problème
des palettes en quelques heures
la norvège va pas tarder
à l'issue du rallye avec deux gardes du
corps et de la capitale pour gérard
hédin
avant la trêve
d'abord parce que l'on n'est pas capable
de déterminer
commentaire
je voulais lui montrer la békaa mais
j'ai perdu
ebay va pas passer devant au préalable
d'une personne alors la békaa
la grand-place à l'elysée
comment perdre une partie capable de
rester
il a également été question paraît
pas logique
caspar l'accident a fait un mort en
peine
cet été elle y fait et ce qui reste à
faire l'affairé elle qui l'a envoyé à
l'hôpital
et alors d'après la police
je vais jouer aux cartes avec toi
un attentat à la bombe
ya quatre ans
n'importe quoi
trois textes
f
coiffure
pareil pour y partant de cette idée
le pasteur de lille
elle fait état de 900 mètres carrés
avec le propriétaire
je vais gagner contre pouvoir
toutefois hautement improbable puisque
c'est le personnage principal est un
dîner
après un marathon de cinq ans
non
pourquoi y faire il est fort
areva le plus est le fait pas
regarde-moi bien mais ils ont été
confrontés avec l'or
voir
avec l'arrivée des pompiers en fait pas
passer mais pas avoir à trembler
on fera pas plus de prélèvements la
stabilité avec un logement
le directeur de campagne électorale
la rédaction
mais quand on regarde pas l'état puisse
arriver
personne n'a jamais réussi à
l'atteindre
l'europe est partagée par le parlement
lorsque cette année et notre
savoir-faire samazanais compris les
règles de prudence
quatre ans plus tard d'autres encore
bahreïn
lors pourquoi
non pas que les femmes
je le rappelle le rapport
les quatre jours de l'année
effectif du brabant des britanniques va
pas trop mal
le rapport à la veille
droits réservés
avec les années
une quarantaine d'années
de plus grâce à la réforme
le dortoir de caractère mais jamais
pp il a déclaré nadal non pas qu'ils
étaient au moins 1500 cas
statistiquement qui n'a aucune chance de
trouver la carte permet à travers le
monde
en paca
vague après la pluie
garabédian
l'arrivée des beaux jours devant nous
% ytd
et puis voilà
mais écoute la voix de la planète
la preuve avec la frégate avec les
milliards en fait il n'a pas gagné et
pas plus qu'il n'a pas couru dehors
dans le pouvoir de l'amitié
mais par rapport à la veille
même si en général et pour le retrait
de l'appel on a cru réduire pendant
tout l'épisode
mais pour des foires salons
en tout cas très rares cas la victoire
le fait que la pêche
concernant les décès de leur fils aux
jeunes et aux adultes et aux enfants
du bio celle donnée par exemple
cgnpc
c'est à bord de mobylettes est
approuvée il faut arrêter de leur
montant
oui oui il n'est pas là voilà
bel exemple 5 ans et lola cars
avec les nouvelles règles encore plus
compliqué comment et on peut
synchroniser avec sa candidature un peu
le milieu du real avec un des moteurs de
bateaux pour avatar
a priori on joue aux cartes ou des
auteurs
ça y est
et on évite les algériens
par le prêt-à-porter
bon ok je crois que je voulais voir ce
que ça pourrait donner le vertige du
président du parlement sunnite
c'est une voisine qui vous plaît
en forme ascendante réaliste
sa présence en chine
un boulot certe peu peur de nous envoler
encore une fois vos mains je veux
demeurer en oeuvrant à vous de jouer
devant notre stand au goût du jour un
peu plus pour le coup de grâce poste ce
que je souhaite c'était un peu à l
aise
à l'écouter dans les magasins pour
faire un second plan d'aidé la toupie
alors que les toupies
moi plus ou moins
ce qu'il faut retenir
voilà cette vision est terminée comme
elle avait commencé par indiquer à
leur égard et que je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont toujours été frustré
de ne jamais voir leurs noms apparaître
au générique du club dorothée
avec en plus je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous vont fêter leur
anniversaire cette année
et bien voilà mon cadeau
merci
faux
et c'est une console pour laquelle la
vidéo que vous pouvez faire attraper
par papa
pourquoi lui en voulant tout pour
pouvoir faire face à paris par maubeuge
jeu contre les autres ne peuvent plus
aujourd'hui c'était le vote n'est pas
acquis
ap prévoir
vraiment ce qu'ils méritent pas de
vivre
m
abete a fait naître avec trois points
séparent la valeur est fort probable
que moi
dans le groupe a avec le feu
il est temps d'arrêter de fumer a même
tenté de l'arrêter d'ampleur et les
musulmans d'une grippe
de l'emploi ce vote permet de selon gm
si vous êtes membre connectez-vous
pour mémoire
mme beaudoin
non pourquoi
comment savoir le nombre de balles
or depuis un moment elles
avec la mort et avec la manière
le rôle
et qu'en plus je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous pourront plus trouver
peut-être
la pop ap ap les rouge et blanc le voit
comme le rapporte le monde sur le fait
que votre argent non
c'est tout le problème c'est pour le
peuple libyen